today i'm joined by maya duke massava
who's a senior writer at the chicago
reader she covers policing housing the
courts and local
social justice movements maya it's great
to speak to you today
thanks for having me on so there are so
many conversations over the last four or
five months that
relate to policing in the united states
we've had the george floyd protests
we've had
sort of more political conflicts between
local state and federal law enforcement
as we saw
federal troops deployed to certain
cities around the united states
one of the things that is sort of
underlying a lot of these conversations
are the issues of police unions as well
as
police immunity in certain situations
and it's
interesting maybe as a place to start
the conversation to think about
a lot of people who tend to be in favor
of democratization of workplaces and in
favor of unions and collective
bargaining
have identified that police unions are a
little bit different that it's not
exactly the same when you're talking
about a union
maybe of delivery drivers and a union
for police officers can you talk a
little bit about
structurally what the differences are
yeah police unions are very different
from a lot of other
public sector unions or private sector
unions so
the i think the key difference begins
with
where the power dynamic lies between the
workers and the bosses
so police officers are employed by a
municipality
and basically unlike any other type of
worker
it's police that are respond
the the municipality depends on the
police for the protection
of uh property and a certain kind of
status quo
so historically police officers have
been this
the strike force against striking
striking workers in other sectors
they have been the uh vehicles for
maintaining segregation and other types
of policies around
that that politicians in the city would
want to perpetuate so
the in the state of illinois like in a
lot of other places
uh police officers and firefighters as
well actually
are prohibited from striking and so when
they sit down to bargain
with their employer which is the city
they
both sides know that the the strike is
not on the table
however there's other ways that cops can
kind of
withhold their labor and be
non-cooperative
to get the kind of contracts they would
like from the city
and the city unlike an you know let's
say like a private
you know steel mill operator or uh
you know uh i don't know any other type
of private business owner
or manager there's there's like limited
there's limited ways that uh that that
kind of withholding of the labor by the
police officers
can be mitigated so you can't you know
you can't easily bring in scabs
essentially to
to fill in the gap that's left by
striking workers or workers they're
withholding their labor in some way
so really what we see time and again um
and i'm specifically especially in
chicago
is the municipality is sort of like
they're really at the mercy of the union
in this in the sense and
historically this is why municipalities
were so uh
resistant to having police unions
because the kind of
view of local officials and also
of of federal judges that litigated you
know decided over lawsuits over
uh police unionization throughout the
20th century was that
police officers really aren't workers
like other types of workers
they are a paramedic military
organization
and just like the military they have to
have their one allegiance be
to their employer to the state that they
serve and they shouldn't have any other
type of
uh you know interest involved in this
and so now that police officers uh are
able to unionize
it's it's really a dynamic in which
they're able to
get a lot more in their contracts and
get a lot more concessions and a lot
more
bargain from a much stronger position
than any other really public or private
sector
uh workforce is this where the uh
unions were able to sort of gain enough
leverage
to develop some of the defaults that are
in place now
in terms of immunity or is that actually
coming from some other structure
yeah so there's as far as the um again
and i know specifics about the the
police contracts in chicago so really
i'm speaking from
from from this place yeah but the a lot
of the
the first the very first police union
contract that police officers in chicago
had which came
in 1980 really started at
with its bedrock being the the
policeman's bill of rights which
uh was modeled on the kind of first
amendment
uh bill of rights type of protections
that developed for criminal suspects and
and people accused of crimes
in the u.s constitution in the in the
20th century and so as that was
happening in the mid-century police
officers who were increasingly accused
of misconduct that were increasingly
dealing with harsher and hearts or disa
discipline from municipalities
they developed this sort of view that
the police need a bill of rights and
they need protections when they're
accused of some kind of brutality or
misconduct
and so the bedrock of the contract here
in chicago has always been this bill of
rights that protects officers from
having to make statements about
uh their behavior on the job in a
certain constraint of time
they're able to know who is accusing
them of their crimes they're able to
coordinate with one another before they
give statements they're able to amend
their statements after
video or audio evidence about the
incident becomes available
so really the core of the contract is
about protecting officers who are
accused of some kind of misconduct
and beyond that there's a lot of other
things like uh provisions that would
require destruction of misconduct
records
there's all kinds of stuff obviously
that's more on the labor side of things
about
hours and overtime and vacation and all
of that uh but basically
yeah the the contract is is now
extremely elaborate
and uh it really it's really
much more um there's much more that off
every time there's something new that's
in the contract which also
of course depends on the political
situation in which the contract is
decided
every time something new is added it's
much more difficult to take it away
and to to renegotiate the contract so
what we see time after time
is uh especially throughout the 90s the
contract becomes more elaborate there's
there's more and more protections and
guarantees for officers
and less and less space for the city to
come in and really radically change
things
in order to say change how officers are
disciplined for example
so in this context when the defund the
police
movement i guess if we call it that uh
got some momentum a few months ago
one of the things that that i said was
i'm unsure that defund is the right
approach
in in all cases and that there are
but my this is just to give you context
for the upcoming discussion
my thought was there there are cases
where there's too much funding for
certain things like militarization of
police there's other cases where
actually
being underfunded leads to some of the
sort of lower hanging fruit policing
that actually causes the problems we're
trying to solve anyway my point was
i laid out some ideas that i think would
be very useful in actually getting at
some of the problems in policing which
include for example a national bad
actors database
to take away the possibility of a police
officer
leaving one department for uh bad
actions being hired elsewhere in the new
department saying we had no idea there
was no way we could have known that
that's what that that's what took place
that this
individual had a bad uh act in their
past
now the obvious obstacle to that would
be every police union would oppose such
a database right i mean is it is it
is it even conceivable that something
like that could get past unions
yeah so every every police union would
oppose that and also
in a lot of places the police the
contracts do
actually provide for the destruction of
police misconduct records
after a certain amount of years wow so
even if you
were wanted to create such a database in
a lot of places you just couldn't
because the records wouldn't even exist
anymore i mean illinois is really an
exceptional case because we've had a lot
of civil rights litigation on this issue
and basically this past june actually
the illinois supreme court decided on a
case
that was um launched that was started by
a
independent journalist and civil rights
activist jamie calvin
in calvin versus chicago the illinois
supreme court decided that
the destruction of police misconduct
records
which were it turned out that the city
wasn't doing it even though the police
union contract said that they were
supposed
to be destroying them after five years
turned out they weren't doing it we've
got records going back to the 60s
and the illinois supreme court found
that uh
actually it's a dead letter provision in
the police union contract that these
records can't and shouldn't be destroyed
because it's a matter of public interest
to continue having them so technically
like in the state of illinois
you could have uh some kind of statewide
database where like
if a cop gets fired which by the way is
extremely extremely rare
for a cop to even have any kind of
discipline based on misconduct
allegations or complaints
but in the rare occasions where they are
disciplined or fired
you know you could technically have this
kind of database that would prevent them
from them going across to a different
municipality and and getting a job there
but i think that one of the other things
and kind of brought this up with your
earlier question about
about the immunity that that officers
have
that the kind of uh immunity from
prosecution for their conduct on the job
what's sometimes called qualified
immunity
or indemnification that stuff doesn't
really
stem from the union contracts themselves
those are provisions that are installed
by state law
so it's the state that indemnifies
officers against
uh essentially liability for the things
they do on the job which is then
why whenever a cop uh you know does
something bad
they are it's the city that has to be
responsible for that conduct it's the
city that gets sued it's the city that
has to pay
and now the conversation that i'm
hearing more and more is about how we
should actually require officers
to carry liability insurance of some
sort for misconduct like sort of like
malpractice insurance for doctors
uh so that they are themselves
financially liable
for their behavior and then if they
mess up enough times then no nobody's
gonna wanna insure them and that's how
you get these kind of
quote-unquote bad apples out of the
force well
that conversation is really dead in the
water as long as there are these state
laws indemnifying officers and on doing
them would be like
a massive massive battle especially in a
state like illinois where
you know it's very blue up in chicago
but then the rest of state is pretty red
uh it would be hard to get republican
state legislation on board for
changing the syndic indemnification
thing but
yeah that's just an additional layer of
complication aside from the contract
that already provides so many
protections for officers
yeah and you know i i think it's
important to be balanced in this
conversation from from the standpoint of
uh as someone like myself who is on the
left and i am concerned
about the state of policing in the
united states i also do recognize that
being a police officer
is different than working in a factory
in a lot of different ways there is a
public responsibility that comes with it
there
is an element of although it's
relatively rare for an officer to be
killed in the line of duty statistically
speaking
it is a possibility that is that is more
real there than in a number of other
jobs so i think the quest
the concern i have is have the has the
infrastructure as you're pointing out
fallen out of balance in the sense that
a lot of this stuff
that leads to problems is codified in
state law as you're pointing out
there's disproportionate power dynamics
and so i guess what i'm trying to point
out to my audience is
i recognize that being a police officer
is different than a lot of other jobs
and in some senses it should be treated
differently but a lot of the
infrastructure you're pointing out
seems to have fallen a little bit out of
balance
yeah there's that and there's also a
third really important
uh piece of this which is uh the culture
inside police departments and that is
the piece that it's
that it's most difficult to kind of
tinker with
or create interventions to change
because
the contract is an expression of a
certain kind of culture in the
department
the uh behavior of officers that we see
time and time and time again
is it is not just an expression of
training it's not just an expression of
the expectations or the rigor or lack
thereof
of the disciplinary apparatus inside the
department it's also an expression of
the culture
and when you have a culture at a police
department that for example
like in chicago you have a situation
where officers get out of the academy
they get connected with their first
field trading officers
and routinely the field training
officers tell the new recruits
forget everything you learn in the
academy this is how we do this job
and then they teach them illegal kind of
techniques that have been found time and
again by the justice department
to be a violation of civil rights it's
it's there's a kind of mentality in a
culture that gets taught
oftentimes it's reinforced already
because
a lot of folks that decide to join the
police department
grow up in neighborhoods where there's a
lot of police neighbors they may be from
police families
it's a kind of intergenerational thing
so personally i think if
we're talking about changing the way
that policing operates in this country
it's not just a matter of
tinkering with the contract it's not
just a matter of changing the laws in
terms of what officers are allowed to do
it's also about addressing culture how
are you going to address the
culture in which members of the
department are walking around with
punisher skulls
on their uniforms you know how are you
going to address a culture in which
members of the department
are making like racist statements in
online you know in online forums
completely openly so that kind of stuff
i think will be
probably difficult to change without
like serious changes in the way that
like these jobs are paid
and uh how promotion works and how you
get ahead in a job like this
and frankly the more the more i see of
what's going on
um this summer the more i think that
like the kind of culture around
weapons and and the fact that this is a
job that
requires you to carry a gun there's an
increasingly as you point out
militarized component to it
um that stuff i think that if if we
don't address how police officers are
armed and what kind of weaponry
uh young men who might want to join the
force the young women who might join the
force
have access to as part of this job we're
probably not going to see a change in
culture because we're going to keep
attracting the same type of people to
this job
well it's it seems to be a very similar
problem to the gun culture problem in
the united states where when we talk
about well look in switzerland
it's this easy to get a firearm or you
can find this other area where everybody
has guns and there's no problem
part of it may be laws but a lot of it
also
is the relationship of americans to
firearms and
and unless you change that you're going
to have a tough tough time but this
actually relates to the policing
question which is
when there are 350 million firearms out
in the united states and
it is true that anybody police come
across
could have a firearm on them and and
possibly
aren't particularly well well trained
with it or whatever the case may be
because it's so easy to get firearms
it seems difficult to deal with the
issue of police and firearms without
dealing with the issue of
350 million firearms in society right
exactly and i think that
as long probably as long as we have such
a heavily armed
general population and people feel like
their only way of being protected and
it's actually true that for some people
their only way of having some kind of
sense of protection and security
especially people living in some of the
poorest neighborhoods in this country
is having a weapon because there
because there's inter-communal
interpersonal violence that happens
regularly that the police do nothing
about
they do nothing to stop um you know
yeah you're gonna have any kind of
movement to disarm the police would
probably
uh haven't even be even more difficult
to
to accomplish its goals than that than
the kind of
defund the police movement that we're
seeing now but
in general like i feel like this whole
situation in kenosha right now
the with this young man who uh
the 17 year old who shot people killed
killed people
you know his whole social media presence
was about supporting the police
supporting president trump you know
being part of a militia taking the
situation in their own hands like
something there's some there's a bleed
over
around a culture of violence and a
culture that like glorifies weapons
and and and and police culture in this
country so
we can at one on the one hand try to
tinker around the edges
of of the of police contracts and the
sort of bureaucracy and
infrastructure that exists to perpetuate
the system
and on the other hand like not address
the culture that's
already existing in these spaces and
allows them to to kind of thrive and
persist
so it's it's a complicated thing to
untangle and
definitely uh the the thing that's in
the power
of our local elected officials and uh
municipalities
is is to not cede so much ground
in the police contract negotiations all
uh complexly intertwined issues as you
say
untangling is probably the right phrase
to uh to apply to it
we've been speaking with maya dukemaseva
who's a senior writer at the chicago
reader
amaya really appreciate your time today